oi oi
[Música]
E aí
é lá onde eu moro na segundo vocês que
mora em terra de terráqueos e aqui
quando eu falo oi terra é conter
minúsculo mesmo se debaixo dos seus pés
faça um redes de eletricidade canais de
água de esgoto
metrôs e nos outros tipos de cabeamento
debaixo da minha casa passa um peixes
Arraias e às vezes até golfinhos passa
por aqui para tirar o sono você deve
estar pensando que eu sou o marinheiro
que eu trabalho em um navio de
transporte de cargas o que quem sabe até
um pescador Mas e se eu te disser que eu
não sou nada disso e que não nasci à
beira do mar eu nasci não assim meio às
ondas o pé na areia mas ainda assim eu
moro no barco eu nasci em Bagé na divisa
com Uruguai e cresci cruzando ruas
aguardando o semáforo Abrir em escutando
o som dos carros dos ônibus o mar para
mim era algo muito distante de visitar
umas férias e jamais pensar de passar
além da arrebentação das ondas eu estou
informática mas acabei largando a faca a
tocar uma banda em São Paulo e mais
tarde acabei me tornando é diretor de
filmes publicitários e sendo sócio da
minha própria produtora em São Paulo e o
determinado momento eu havia lançado 13
filmes que deveriam ser feitos em 3
meses para um grande evento em São Paulo
e eu estava no auge da minha carreira na
hora que levanto minha formação Eu
também ganhei um tique no olho direito e
o movimento involuntário no braço a cada
minuto mais ou menos e eu tinha 33 anos
e começava a cara quando tiver 66 eu vou
morrer eu acho e por fim depois de uma
série de exames era apenas um Burnout
que eu recuperei uns seis meses depois
eu digo apenas brincando mas é algo que
atinge trinta por cento dos
trabalhadores do Brasil e muito
provavelmente alguns de vocês que estão
escutando escutando agora já passaram
por isso só que ao fim de seis meses eu
já enxergava aqui eu não poderia
continuar vivendo daquele jeito passei a
me questionar sobre como é possível
alcançarmos algo na nossa carr a nossa
vida eu mesmo tempo nos sentimos tão
Miseráveis
passei a me incomodar com a ideia de
aqui os filmes que eu havia feito após
um ano do seu lançamento já não valiam
absolutamente nada do que os produtos
mudavam e de forma muito veloz o filme
do super carro de 2008 já não valia
absolutamente nada em 2009 EA cada ano
mais veloz e mais descartável Eu amo a
tecnologia e sem dúvida lá para porciona
coisas incríveis como poder trabalhar em
um veleiro por exemplo nem tanto muitas
vezes Acabamos nos enganando com as
tecnologias que prometem solucionar uma
série de tarefas e nos Estados com mais
tempo quando o carro surgiu ele deveria
fazer com que as tiras assim em menos
tempo para não deslocar de um ponto ao
outro cortando as viagens acontece que
atualmente 31 por cento dos brasileiros
passa mais de uma hora Tô no trânsito e
eu já conheci que ficasse 4 horas por
dia no trânsito em São Paulo não é
difícil de encontrar e o e-mail por sua
vez os pouparia tempo de escrever uma
carta e até o correio colocar lá comprar
selo esperar ela chegar
mas acontece aqui hoje é quase
impossível você conseguir ter tempo de
ler todos e-mails que chegam na sua
caixa de entrada não acho que a culpa é
da tecnologia mas parece que a gente é
muito melhor criando ela do que sabemos
a ela com sabedoria especialmente
pensando coletivamente
filósofos físicos matemáticos e Curiosos
vem tentando compreender o que é o tempo
há séculos na verdade milênios por isso
eu não vou aqui fazer nenhuma definição
sobre o que ele seria contudo eu posso
dizer que eu já me dei de cara com ele
correndo rápido bem na minha frente e eu
senti a forte presença do tempo quando
me toquei que ele era um recurso muito
mais eu e mais luxuoso do que qualquer
outro na minha vida eu sei que nesse
mundo quase ninguém tem tempo sobrando
Ou pelo menos não tenho tempo que
gostaria de ter às vezes nos damos conta
do Óbvio no dia vamos morrer e por mais
que pensar sobre isso não seja tão
prazeroso é importantíssimo Pois é essa
premissa que traz o centro de gravidade
da nossa vida por lugar certo ela nos dá
uma certa urgência
necessária para encararmos com
sinceridade as perguntas Será que essa
vida é que eu quero ver será que aqui
que eu quero estar é muito comum ouvimos
desde cedo sobre a importância de se
planejar financeiramente
e torna-se cada vez mais fácil encontrar
livros cursos consultorias que tratam
desse tema porém não é muito comum
alguém se planejar quanto ao tempo que
gasta na sua vida pessoal o tempo que
gastamos com a nós do trabalho com
visitas a clientes a frase dinheiro é um
tempo que gastamos com algo que não é
importante mas sim algo útil algum
instrumental E que provavelmente nos
proporcionará recursos para que a gente
consiga realizar coisas que realmente
são importantes
ser feliz na verdade inútil inútil
Porque tudo que importa na vida é inútil
não serve para realizar algo Já que é o
fim já tem valor em si mesmo poucas
coisas na vida tem esse valor em si
mesmas não projeto o seu valor na
consequência de sua existência o seu uso
a felicidade é uma delas todos nós
queremos viver mais mas o que exatamente
mais será que mais É apenas o número de
anos pelos quais percorremos ou Seria
algo além seria mais na verdade a
quantidade de experiências que
conseguimos viver experiências como
conhecer pessoas
é isso aprofundar sim histórias testar
novos gostos e cheiros se emocionar com
mais frequência eu posso te dizer que é
possível que você conhece alguém com 35
que já viveu muito mais do que outra
pessoa com 76 anos e acredite esse viver
não está necessariamente conectado a
quanto dinheiro você tem e sim ao com
permeável você está para aquilo que você
vier a escrever para quem que possa te
mudar o modo que você repara a vida e é
reparado por ela e 2014 eu tive a sorte
de a minha vida experimentar os dois
sentidos que essa palavra reparar
não é porque conheci pessoas que
moravam em Veleiros ao longo da Costa
Brasileira
e eu reparei porque foi capaz de
observar algo novo e maravilhoso e
também porque a partir de então passei a
consertar a minha vida fazer alguns
reparos que eram necessários aquele
momento foi um choque veio pessoas
vivendo num mundo tão paralelo
Alienígena ali entre duas megalópoles de
São Paulo e do Rio de Janeiro Isso me
ajudou a encontrar um objetivo que eu
tinha que era de fazer o trabalho mais
perene capaz de Resistir um pouco mais o
tempo então eu resolvi gravar um
documentário sobre essa outra forma de
viver acontece aqui no meio do caminho
eu acabei gostando demais essa
brincadeira para gravar só uma vez e
acabei fazendo um canal no YouTube junto
com Aline minhas mulher e que Contasse a
vida de pessoas que moram a Bordo de
veleiros no Brasil e no mundo o
documentário que imaginei se transformou
em diversas histórias coletadas ao longo
da Costa Brasileira eu não pensava em
mais nada Até que em 2017 Eu me mudei
para o veleiro junto com Aline Senna que
teve uma enorme participação em toda
essa história o meu canal foi crescendo
e após cinco anos se tornou o maior
canal sobre náutica em língua portuguesa
do mundo Talvez isso se dê pelo fato de
que apesar dos vídeos se passarem no mar
não é bem sobre Náutica que falamos lá o
mar é um cenário onde tudo acontece a
vida a Bordo é muito diferente da vida
tradicional que a maioria conhece ela é
bela ela é minimalista e traz
responsabilidades que não são comuns em
terra e foi capaz de mudar uma série de
problemas que eu ainda não tinha
percebido eu comecei a me perguntar se
valia o tempo de trabalho para pagar um
milhão de reais um cubículo no centro de
uma cidade grande barulhenta co o que
alguém gasta quatro horas no trânsito
por dia sabe quando há um ruído baixinho
em um determinado ambiente e depois de
um tempo você deixa de natalo era como
se o ruído tivesse parado e agora eu
conseguisse perceber que ele estava ali
durante anos
perdemos a noção e os treinamento para
várias coisas na nossa vida coisas que
nos machucam que são pouco eficientes e
que gastamos muito do nosso tempo
eficiência e Juventude Quem mora em um
barco pessoalmente de forma nômade
precisa repensar Muitas das coisas que
na cidade estão geralmente no piloto
automático como conseguir água
eletricidade internet cada barco um
laboratório de soluções que poderão
servir de estudo para compará-las com
que a gente faz na cidade eu vivo com 20
litros de água doce por dia por exemplo
Mas não se preocupe porque eu tomo banho
todos os dias com água quente e
vai chegar nesse consumo que mora bordo
precisa prender vários truques como usar
uma bombinha acionada por pedal na pia
da cozinha desligar o chuveiro no meio
do banho mas o mais importante é sabemos
de onde vem a água cada um desses 20
litros eu sei de onde eles vêm muitas
vezes eu vou com bot até uma cachoeira e
no Rio e pega um galões e trago para o
meu barco uma vez por semana na cidade é
só abrir a torneira e a maioria das
pessoas hoje não tem a menor noção da
dificuldade que é conseguir os recursos
que a gente usa Talvez o fato de hoje os
brasileiros em média gastarem cê 54
litros por dia de água doce tem algum
reflexo nisso eu descobri que nem sempre
seu recursos limitados é algo
absolutamente ruim quando ele tava os
vídeos na cidade a vida e felicidade à
vontade então eu não me preocupava muito
com isso o tempo que eu computador ficar
ligado no primeiro barco que eu morei as
placas solares no pq e se havia também
porque não lembro de baterias e eu tinha
que aproveitar o máximo das horas do Sol
isso me fazia organizar o trabalho e
focado é uma maneira inacreditável e
descobri que conseguia realizar a mesma
coisa em um espaço de tempo muito
inferior sobrando mais tempo para outras
coisas importantes na minha vida então
eu acho que aprendi que há muitas
barreiras e limites que a gente põe na
vida e que não são absolutos a gente
educada para acreditar que elas são mas
é só uma barreira cultural o trabalho
remoto é um exemplo já fazem muitos anos
que tecnologicamente ser possível um
grande número de pessoas trabalhar de
casa desafogando o trânsito e podendo
moral de gostaria Travessa eu nunca
trabalho remoto não traga problemas ele
traz mas o ponto que eu quero trazer
aqui é dizer que precisou a quebra de
uma barreira cultural para que isso
acontece não física ou tecnológica
acredita-se que a nossa espécie surgiu a
uns 300 mil anos e apenas nos últimos 10
mil anos nos tornamos sedentários
certamente Há muitos fenótipos que se
desenvolveram para estilo de vida
novamente e eu arrisco dizer que muitos
dos problemas que temos hoje são uma
luta contra esses extintos inclusive o
Bom exemplo é talvez por causa disso a
gente gosta tanto de viajar e conhecer
lugares diferentes isso nos faça tão bem
vivendo de forma nômade o veleiro eu
pude descobrir qual o tipo de tempo de
vida que eu quero contabilizar é algo
realmente muito difícil de dar uma
definição determinar exatamente o que é
porque para cada pessoa tem um
significado apesar disso desenvolver uma
ferramenta e para checar o com
importante é uma parcela de tempo minha
que foi gasto durante duas décadas o
dirigir de casa para o trabalho
incontáveis vezes Em alguns momentos
três horas por dia é um tempo
considerável e o que eu lembro desses
momentos
praticamente nada algum acidente algum
caso engraçado mas praticamente nada
para mim esses deslocamentos foram todos
iguais por outro lado em travessias a
vela até mesmo algumas bastante triviais
como de Paraty e Ilhabela que eu já fiz
muitas e muitas vezes eu consigo lembrar
muitas coisas diferenciar várias delas
aquela que golfinhos me perseguiram
aquela outra que foi a primeira o dia
que atravessa chorando ou a mais
perfeita delas
e elas têm identidades que as
diferenciam essas histórias particulares
de cada viagem contribuíram para que eu
me tornasse quem eu sou isso sem falar
das viagens incríveis que não se faça o
dia mas essas colei terramar também eu
quero que chamar a atenção para a
necessidade desenharmos a nossa vida de
uma maneira que a rotina o dia a dia
mesmo que seja cansativo seja também
interessante e memorável o problema é
que muitos de nós tem uma série de
correntes que nos prendem e nos impedem
de ir além do horizonte que conhecemos e
de buscar e descobrir essa vida que é
interessante eu na minha vida tinha
acumulado uma série de compromissos
financeiros e sociais que me tiravam uma
boa parte da liberdade é como um
analisarmos quanto a liberdade um país
constituição o governo te dá e essa é
uma das condições mais importantes para
exercermos a nossa felicidade e a nossa
cidadania algo que devemos estar sempre
atentos defender Ah mas isso só definir
uma parte da Liberdade que você tem
quase ninguém se preocupa enquanto a
liberdade e você mesmo se dá porque
Claro a liberdade não valor definitivo
absoluto astutamente mais importante de
outros pelo menos não adianta termos sol
ela trocamos a nossa liberdade por viver
um casamento para termos filhos ou ter
um bom emprego e todas as coisas são
trocas justas que vale a pena mas se
você não cuidar com o tempo vai acumular
uma série de pequenas amarras menos
importantes e que vão tornar sua vida
muito pesada e difícil de manobrar eu
conheço alguns amigos que tem muito
dinheiro mas que para mudar de vida em
uma curva de 90 graus talvez eles
precisem de 10 anos ou mais
talvez nem consigam nossa vida tem
muitos funcionários não têm dinheiro
para fechar a empresa por exemplo o meu
objetivo de vida é está pronta para
fazer uma curva dessas a hora que eu
quiser eu quero uma o e ágil manobrável
isso para mim a liberdade e viver em um
barco me fez alcançar isso hoje a minha
vida tem capacidade de manobra mas para
isso você precisa focar no que realmente
essencial para sua vida é muito difícil
ter uma vida que a como um barco pesado
muito lotado de coisas e ao mesmo tempo
ser ágil é preciso descobrir quais são
as suas correntes
quais vale a pena manter ou não não não
existe acreditado que cortar custos é
como cortar grama o cortar as unhas Pois
então ter uma vida simples é a mesma
coisa é preciso constantemente tirar o
que não é essencial Ah pois as amarras
vão sempre se acumulando na vida e
vivendo em um veleiro isso é muito caro
enxergar Não é só para o espaço pequeno
que que temos a Bordo mas também porque
mudando de cidade em cidade é toda hora
conseguimos identificar também essas
correntes nas relações nos costumes na
rotina muitas dessas correntes são
extremamente difíceis de cortar temos
personagens que nos definem em cada um
dos Campos onde convivemos uma
personagem do trabalho outra no almoço
com os pais no jogo de futebol é setra
muitas as mudanças necessárias para uma
vida em um veleiro ou qualquer outro
sonho de uma vida mais simples não cabem
no personagem que você tem a cidade o
tiram algo essencial dele é o fato é que
para fazer a sua vida se transformar
Essa maneira você precisa criar outro
personagem quando eu fui morar na borda
comecei a mostrar minha vida de outros
que moram borda também evidentemente não
existe um pessoas que moravam em
Veleiros mas muitos me dizem que certa
forma eu inventei o cara que mora borda
esse personagem O que é um grande
exagero Eu apenas mostrei pra esse cara
que mora bordo viver sem ar condicionado
com pouca água o gerando menos lixo não
é algo que o faz sentir o menor eu lhe
prejudicar realmente é motivo de orgulho
algo para ser orgulhar com os amigos
para mudar de vida de forma feliz e
plena é importante aceitar e criar uma
imagem de si mesmo que funcione dentro
do estilo de vida que você gostaria de
ver caso contrário tudo vai sempre
incomodar você e você nunca vai
conseguir aproveitar o que que aquela
vida tem de melhor oferecer porque você
está sempre tentando encaixar algo que
não cabe ali
eu acho que algo muito importante para
quem vive em um mundo que precisa de
mudanças como nosso e talvez uma das
coisas mais interessantes que a vida a
Bordo tem para ensinar nós temos a
capacidade de reinventar as nossas vidas
com menos recursos mas ainda assim criar
algo que muitos julgariam como uma vida
muito mais interessante plena e cheia de
novas experiências e
E aí